hey guys how's it going so today we are
going to be making something and pretty
awesome recently I went to the Indy 500
with Steak and Shake and while I was
there they showed me how to make their
new Oreo red velvet milkshake it's a
special limited edition milkshake along
with their new peppercorn bacon steak
burger which they also showed me how to
make as you guys know here I've tried to
make a burger previously and it didn't
work out so well so I'm gonna leave that
to the professionals
I thought there's a small chance I might
be able to handle the milkshake one of
my favorite things they use real red
velvet cake so you know what that means
we need to make a cake
that's really read and now into the oven
we go let's start our milkshake process
I don't have an ice cream scooper
options which like the cake is almost
done I'll prep our ice cream it looks
good it'd be a little bit more this is
definitely not up to say can shake
standards so I'm sorry second shake put
in a few Oreos there's not a special red
velvet syrup that I don't have so maybe
I'll just put in some extra cake to
accommodate for the fact that I'm
missing a few ingredients so bit of milk
for the milkshake I legit just pull this
out of the oven it's gonna be so hot
this icing is gonna melt as soon as I
put it on it oh boy
they had a nicer piece of cake than this
just set your expectations really load
you guys set it low and you'll be so
impressed with everything I create we're
going to put this in our milkshake this
is still a really hot cake just like an
oven
this is this is will old Florida it's
not frosted like steak and shakes but
the best that I have great whipped cream
works I also don't have any cherries
which is really upsetting because
they're like my favorite thing ever so
this milkshake is gonna be quite subpar
oh I thought that I would have some but
I don't this thing never goes on
correctly now we're gonna mix up our
milkshake and we're gonna be ready to go
the whole package clearly not something
the way should be doing man stay back I
think it looks mix I think it looks next
oh god I miss it at our whipped topping
ha come on here we go
they also added some cookie crumbles on
the top for a little bit flavor this is
basically the complete opposite of what
you would get at thicken Jake but how to
do a side-by-side comparison I think I'm
just gonna let the professionals handle
that all right guys thank you for
watching I'm gonna go clean up my
kitchen now let me know what you guys
think a stake in Jake coz new Oreo red
velvet milkshake if you guys happen to
stop by this summer and get yourself one
send me a picture also be sure to check
out their new peppercorn bacon steak
burger it was quite delicious I also had
one while I was in Indiana and
thankfully that was not something that
we tried to recreate here today I'll see
you guys in the next video let me know
in the comments below what you'd like me
to make next just make it something
easier
you're easier than a milkshake please